If we just take God out of it.
Might there not be something you're scientific beliefs can't explain.
My name is Matt.
I'm 41 years old.
I'm a pastor.
I'm Gil k,
uh,
40,
40 years old.
I,
uh,
let minister but his church.
I'm Andrew.
I'm 42 and I'm a chemist.
Okay.
I'm Jess.
I'm 36 and I'm a volcanologist.
I'm dawn.
I'm 64.
I'm a paleontologist and geologist.
I'm Amy.
I'm 53,
and I am a rabbi.
This is literally my greatest fear that I'd be all known in the circle.
I believe that this world was created.
Uh,
I've placed my faith in a god that is infinitely creative in what he's made.
He then deserves my worship and my affection as the last night I was talking to
my wife,
I was like,
what if there's a question that I'm the one,
she's like,
just stay where you are.
I was like,
I don't know.
Big problem.
Is that mean to you?
Start talking with creator and I babble.
Creation is in most of my entire career as an evolutionary biologist and
paleontologist,
it brings in a whole category of things that violate my rules as a scientist as
well.
And when I stepped back from that,
especially when I step back where I started as a religious person when I was
younger,
I look at this and they say,
you know,
if anything,
what we see now about the universe shows how poorly designed it is now sloppy it
is and how painful it is and all these things which don't speak to a very
benevolent creator because if anything it makes him look bad.
Um,
I don't believe in a supernatural God.
I'm a reconstructionist Jew.
For me,
I don't rely on a supernatural creator in order to remain astounded at the
beauty of this world.
It's sloppy.
It's the world,
right?
It's the world.
We're sloppy,
the world of sloppy,
but it's also incredibly magical and yeah,
and worthy of awe and um,
and respect and that it's here is amazing that we're here is amazing and I want
to live in relationship to that amazement.
Okay.
I never look to science to go like,
is murder right or wrong?
I look to science to say how many murders were committed last week?
You know,
that,
that's what I want to know.
And then say,
is there a trend?
What is the of these murders,
blah,
blah blah.
And then we use a,
you know,
we use different tools,
I guess is the best way of putting it to,
um,
to assess whether or not we should be murdering people.
Where did,
where did those morals come from then?
I think they're innate in humans.
All societies have had certain things that agree on him.
Carlos,
a religious background and so on.
We don't require a deity or any kind of religion to give us those things and we
come with them as part of our species.
And for me,
it's not so much a science can answer more questions,
but science certainly can guide us in a lot of ways,
especially when moral questions and conflict with reality is we've now learned.
Yeah,
okay.
I've got serious gaps in my faith that require as supernatural answer.
I mean,
I can't,
I can't understand.
And fathom the complexities of the universe all on my own.
I'm a Christian.
I had at a church service,
someone had a hurt shoulder and they said my shoulder really hard,
so you pray for my shoulder to get better.
I'm be honest with you,
I have about 5% faith that that's going to work out,
but I pray for him.
I put my hand on her shoulder and I said,
you know,
I want this shoulder to get healed in Jesus name.
And I walked away thinking,
oh no.
Another disappointing the person who didn't get healed today.
Well,
the next morning that person called me and say,
you wouldn't believe it.
My shoulder feels a 100% better.
I still don't have a good answer to that.
Um,
but I just know every time I get an answer or an opportunity to extra my
exercise,
my faith in a supernatural way,
I want to take that opportunity because I just don't know what the answer might
be.
It could be something terrific.
I totally agree with you.
I liked you.
It's,
when you say 5% I pretty much feel the same way.
Yeah,
I didn't buy hometown in Japan.
We have this kind of service to set up console the spirits in the lines.
When we chant we're like out,
you know,
an hour or half an hour maybe.
Then everybody feels like,
oh you feel so peaceful.
But then I can't quite explain it like logically and that's,
that's stuff that sits separately shin in that situation.
Science is all about understanding what we can understand and the science,
you're pretty much not allowed to even consider the supernatural because it's
beyond testable hypotheses.
It's beyond anything that you can evaluate in any what we might call an
objective manner.
We are comfortable with the idea that we do not know something and we say we did
not know something and that was some day we may find the answer.
We may not.
There's a lot out there that we can't explain.
It has absolutely nothing to do with my beliefs.
I was raised Catholic and um,
I'm just as confused now as I was then about what's really going on.
You know,
there,
there is the small amount of stuff we can explain.
I don't need to have a belief about it.
I don't even need to go beyond that.
And just just to decide that it's magnificent and terrifying all at the same
time and just kind of leave it at that.
So I think your answer to the question
would have been yes.
I mean cause I think you might agree that there's stuff that you can't even know
to test yet.
So maybe there's something beyond scientific theory and proof that we don't even
know yet.
And I'm not saying God,
I don't need,
just take God out of it.
Might there not be something right.
Your scientific beliefs can't explain.
That's right.
Certainly.
But it also,
in my philosophy,
I don't see any point in putting any kind of supernatural label on it.
Right.
As an explanation.
It's just not solving
problem.
Yeah.
Well I'm so glad you're with me cause I didn't want to be here all by myself.
I mean I just see purpose for our lives that extends beyond the here and now
that there is an eternity that God wants to have with us.
His love for us is so deep that it desires to have a continued relationship with
us.
Uh,
as,
as far as time goes on.
Because I live in Long Beach,
I go down to the beach and I see the waves in the ocean at,
at,
at the beach.
They,
they come ashore and they leave.
We compare that to life.
We take different shapes and different forums and the length of the way,
we have no idea.
You'll show up in different locations which are happening to control the idea
that we just,
this moment trolleys shape that we have this,
this life and trying to preserve it in how,
and then we kind of missing the whole point that we are actually that greater
ocean
in my limited capacity as a individual human,
like in this form and this shape.
I have no idea how can I possibly have any idea about what that being ocean is
going to mean or B.
And so I know that,
uh,
I will continue to be part of the universe,
but not as,
as me.
Not as this.
I would agree with that.
I mean,
I see no evidence from anything that I can observe or anything that was debt
goes on that is more than just wishful thinking that humans in some form are
going to exist in some afterlife or they're recognizable and their identities
carry on.
Um,
when I was a kid,
I asked my dad,
um,
if our pets would be waiting for us in heaven when we died.
And my dad said no,
and I was shocked and I was like,
why would there not be pets in heaven?
And my dad's like,
well,
there are animals.
And I'm like,
why not my animals?
And he's like,
well,
they're just like a generic cat and a generic dog.
And I went,
wait,
what?
And so at that point,
that's when I started to question like,
wait a minute,
what happens next?
And,
uh,
and yeah,
I'm,
I'm kind of a,
you know,
with a lot of you guys here and just saying that,
look,
you know,
wouldn't it be great if we could go on and on and on?
But I think because we don't see any evidence for it,
I have to be in the camp of,
well,
we get this one shot.
Make the most of it.
Do the best you can,
and then when it's done,
you know,
don't have any regrets,
live with doing as much as you could.
That is good.
So that you will live on in the memories of those who stay behind.
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
Your Dad told you,
your dog's not going to heaven.
What a crushing thing.
Uh,
you know,
all good dogs go to heaven.
It must be true.
I think he was trying to do like,
let me down gently,
like some days I'm like totally zen.
I'm totally like solely,
they're like,
it's okay.
It's all one and I will just not exist.
I'm usually not as afraid of death as I am of dying.
Like I'm,
I'm afraid of dying because I've seen some really bad dying.
I'm very afraid of pain and of,
you know,
the process of dying.
All right.
I lost both my parents are from counselor,
so I witnessed the both process.
My mom died,
uh,
over,
um,
30 years ago.
And,
uh,
it was,
it was painful to witness that are my mom.
My mom kind of was health deteriorate.
My Dad,
uh,
went through the same process but then he was runs writing letters as,
just really coincides woods boorish teachings that I'm having a wonderful day.
I'm really grateful for everybody who support us.
We have a saying that every day is a,
as you say,
the greatest day.
I can see that,
you know,
intellectually I can understand it intellectually,
but I just wasn't sure if I could,
I could feel if I,
I would be able to say something like that if I'm put in that situation.
Man,
I'm such a skeptic and that includes questioning my own,
my own beliefs.
Um,
especially if I form a hypothesis and I'm working on an experiment.
I mean you always kind of wanted to go a certain way and you have to do your
best to remove that,
that bias.
And then,
um,
some,
a lot of times if you're in research just doesn't work.
One of the things I tell students,
cause I work with students a lot with my nonprofit organization and I tell them,
you know,
as they're journeying into becoming scientists and they come from all sorts of
different backgrounds and I just say,
look,
don't ever work with anyone who's afraid to admit that they don't know something
or that they're wrong.
Like those are really important qualities,
whether it's in science or any aspect of life.
They'll the whole fun and being a scientist is trying to break things.
Uh,
and I actually wanted to start a journal of scientific mistakes so that we could
share with each other what went wrong.
Because too often we only talk about the successes.
And I think it's very valuable to also know what failure is and what it teaches
us.
Cause there's such a healthy thing.
I always think it's a healthier thing.
So when I've already see younger monastics or priests,
like yeah,
go ahead and question,
question me or question which you do and then be okay.
And you need to understand,
understand intellectually.
But at the same,
I want you to understand their things.
That's beyond this intellectual understanding.
So that's an in Breen I'm recognizable part of understand that comes only
through experience.
Really interesting.
Nice to meet you.
Good to meet you too.
Hey guys,
this is John and Kendra.
Thank you so much for watching this episode of middle ground.
Make sure I let us know what you think in the comments below,
and as always,
please be sure to click,
subscribe and watch more of our staff.
We'll see you next time.
Okay.